[Music]  this season on the drew barrymore show  one working girl takes on the world  you know i have a head for business and  a bod for  single-breasted suits  with her signature passion and appetite  for life  this sandwich it's so  good it is so  good it's the best sandwich i have ever  had  i think i'll have one of those as a  matter of fact you make it a double  whether you're a miranda looking for her  steve  or just a slice of pizza  cheers i love you i love you  this season will leave you sleepless  with excitement thanks to a little help  from the drew crew it's you  it's me  starring interior designer mikel welch  chef hilar valdez  co-anchor ross matthews  and host drew barrymore  in the drew barrymore show  season two  welcome home  you